yesterday I was at the Indiana State
Fair and I got to see the world's
largest boar he weighs more than 1,100
pounds and he can't stand up because his
body is too big for his tiny little legs
and what you ask is the name of the
world's largest boar walking tall tank
walking tall the world's largest boar
who can't walk reminds me a little bit
of America's health care system
depending on your perspective
he's either impressively huge or
distressingly huge so what do you do
when you have a pig that's so big you
can't walk you either kill him put him
on a diet or keep feeding it which is
more of us with the health care debate
boils down to I want to talk in a
non-partisan way about the health care
debate but I don't want to talk about
death panels because they're not in the
bill and the stupid unsophisticated
debate about them has distracted from a
really large and significant issue so
here are two things but pretty much
everyone conservative or liberal agrees
upon one the United States spends way
too much of its gross domestic product
on health care and to our current health
care system is radically unfair whether
you have good health care in America is
dependent largely on whether you work
for a big company because big companies
have to provide health benefits and
second whether you have a pre-existing
condition which a lot of times isn't
your fault some people argue that we
need to sort of large-scale
government-run insurance companies the
so-called public option which everyone
would be able to buy into and poor
people would pay less than richer people
and in this huge government-run in
sherwood negotiate lower costs for
procedures and also cut down on the
number of procedures used now even
though the public option would not in
any way eliminate private insurers
private insurers still hate the public
option because they know that the
government-run insurance company will be
larger and therefore more able to
negotiate lower prices which will in
turn make the public insurance less
expensive which will make people less
inclined to use private insurance then
you have the people who want
with the pigs on a diet who say that
instead of a public option we can create
these sort of nonprofit insurance
companies that will then have to compete
with private insurance and because they
won't be for-profit companies they'll be
incentivized not to work for the
shareholders in the company but instead
to work for the patients they represent
now of course the downside of equipped
to take on the diet plan is that you
still end up with tens of millions of
people who have no health insurance
whatsoever and then other people who
don't want to health care system
overhaul they want to keep feeding the
pig a lot of them people are happy with
the current state of their health care
and to be frank I think they probably
don't want to pay for people who make
stupid decisions here's the underlying
problem even though a lot of people are
screaming
I don't want socialism no socialism in
America right now we have a lot of
socialism we share the cost of schools
and roads and the military we also
currently have socialized medicine we
just have an outrageously bloated and
inefficient system of socialized
medicine because there are hospitals in
America where anyone can go and get
treatment that treatment may eventually
bankrupt you and it may be a poor
quality but you can get it and I would
argue that it's the inefficiency of our
socialized medicine that in the end
makes health care so much more expensive
than it is anywhere else in the world is
health care a privilege or is it a right
if it's a privilege even if it's a
really desirable privilege like indoor
plumbing we need to stop giving health
care of any kind to uninsured people who
can't pay for it in advance
and thinks the reason we continue to
treat people who are uninsured is
because we don't believe that health
care is a privilege we believe that it
is a right and if it is a right like
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness it is a responsibility of a
government to protect that right
you